deep beneath your feet is a subterranean
melting pot a fiery Inferno ready to
boil over at any moment anywhere or
anytime imagine that today is the day
the ground beneath your feet gave way
and the Earth's crust rips open giant
rifts caused unparalleled destruction
and city streets are covered in
scorching lava things are about to get a
little toasty just how much damage would
this do and would we even stand a chance
of surviving this is what F and here's
what would happen if Earth's crust
suddenly opened up our planet is
geologically active the bad news is we
can't tell when or where something
called a large igneous province or Li P
could form Li Pease our geological
features formed when a massive amount of
magma flows onto the Earth's surface
this can result in regional scale uplift
continental rifting breaking up the
ground and climate changes Li PS do some
major spring cleaning but their house is
the earth itself most of us know about
an asteroid hitting the earth and wiping
out the dinosaurs but most people don't
know that the earth nearly got
devastated by a large igneous province
that formed in Siberia 250 million years
ago now imagine that we had to deal with
a colossal Li P like that today how much
damage would have caused urban areas
would be decimated by the rift causing
extensive destruction and those quakes
they're just a preview next the lava
makes its grand entrance once here it's
on the warpath farmland needed for
raising crops would be
incinerated bodies of water like lakes
streams and rivers would be vaporized if
there was enough lava and depending on
how fast the lava flows endangered
species would be wiped out if they
couldn't relocate in time it would also
devastate the economy schools businesses
and hospitals would be ravaged along
with infrastructure like highways power
generating facilities gas lines and
water mains oh and that beautiful new
house you bought it's covered in lava
your new car it's under lava and what
about you well according to Oregon State
University lava moves on a flat slope
like Hawaii's Mount Kilauea at a maximum
of 10 km/h the average speed people walk
at is 5 km/h and average running speed
is about 13 km/h so if you were good at
track and field and how's your time to
shine
but lava flowing downhill like mount
Nyiragongo can speed along at 100
kilometers per hour
good luck outrunning that in addition to
the extreme heat burning melting and
destroying anything it touches
lava releases particles into the air and
toxic gases such as sulfur carbon
dioxide and halogen even if you can get
out of the lavas path you're still in
danger from breathing the gas and
particles in the air how long could you
hold your breath
so with all that is it possible we could
come out of this ok well there's no
how-to manual or strategy to combat the
formation of an L IP how and when they
form is a pretty complex subject
requiring a lot of scientific
disciplines to understand but it's not
like it's really gonna happen right well
it's definitely possible in 2018 Mount
Kilauea in Hawaii erupted and destroyed
more than 700 homes now Kilauea is a
volcano rather than
a large igneous province but it makes it
clear that magma is still flowing to the
Earth's surface and there's plenty more
down in the Earth's core at mantle so
maybe we should start planning for it
there are procedures in place to deal
with volcanic eruptions and earthquakes
so why can't there be one for Li Pease
our planet is going to continuously
shift and change forever it makes us
wonder what other mysteries could be
brought to the surface with these
geological shifts what if the entire
planet was cut in half well that's a
story for another what-if